hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the ADHD quiz now this
quiz is legitimate because it comes from
a website called totally a DD so you
know they take it seriously here in
whatever this answer says means that I
have gratuitous amounts of attd ADHD I
actually do have a TV I take medication
for it and I am very forgetful when I'm
not on it but I've never taken a test
like this before I've taken a legitimate
like test and I've been tested for hours
and hours and I did that but that's all
who cares what they say those
are doctors this is the Internet these
are the people that I trust so let's see
what are the signs for those of you
don't know what ADHD is is its ongoing
and impairing when an attention
procrastination overwhelm and
restlessness are constant frustrating
problems that undermine many areas of
your life it's a disorder this quizzes
are men approved by two independent ADHD
specialists two it will give you a sense
of whether or not you have this mindset
but will not replace a proper assessment
well to that let's take it I
understand there are 18 quick questions
first Explorer 9 in detention and focus
of course life is rarely black-and-white
if what we were describing happens to
you regularly then said yes
it's like know if it's hardly ever or
not at all alright more attention to
detail I often make small mistakes in my
work I skim reading I tend to rush
things
I mess up dates get numbers wrong or
failed to notice typos often overlooked
details and filling out forms forget to
add attachments emails yeah pretty much
I forget all the time if that
doesn't mean anything I'm easily
distracted I find it difficult to stick
the longer tasks even leisure activities
and they go off to do something else or
I end up doing things several times at
once I struggle to follow through on
complex tasks short deadlines work best
for me yeah pretty much then annoys all
my friends because they never ever stick
to what I say I was gonna do but I
doesn't mean poor listener I find I'm
easily distracted during long
conversations I tend to now I may be
looking right at someone but I'm lost in
thought my mind often wanders well ok
but who doesn't that apply to these are
like general like horoscope questions
don't follow instructions I prefer to
jump right in rather than read through
instructions guides of recipes I don't
have regular routines of work or home I
struggle with schedules or plans I'm not
being obstinate I know what to do
I just can't seem to do it ah yeah I
every single IKEA furniture package I've
ever opened I never look at the
instructions until it's too late
I feel disorganized God do not look at
my room at my apartment right now do not
look into the chaos of my life I create
long to-do lists and then find them
overwhelming planning a big project
feels daunting I procrastinate because I
can't see where to start to figure out
what I need well yeah but now I feel bad
because I've been answering this ever I
mean I know I have it but it doesn't
need to prove it so succinctly I avoid
tasks that require sustained mental
effort I struggle to finish things that
demand a lot of focus for a long period
of time other times I get in the zone
and hyper focus I avoid routine tasks
that feel monotonous repetitive or
boring when faced with the big important
task I will do a bunch of trivial chores
instead I hate paperwork now see this is
where I can actually say no I love a
project that is monotonous to all hell
like digging a hole in minecraft or
working on a big ass compilation like I
like doing that it's only starting it
it's only starting that gets me a
problem but once I'm in I am in I am
laser focused I love that so I'm gonna
say no often lose things I need Oh God
once again in the mess of my apartment
don't look over there but it's a goddamn
mess the freaky thing is gay us yeah I'm
easily distracted by conversation noises
or activities happening around me I'm
often lost in thought my mind will be
far away imagining interesting ideas
situations or conversations pretty smart
but a bit absent-minded I've been called
a daydreamer oh yeah right up
complimenting up my own ass about how
smart I am well yes I'm a genius
but yeah I'm distracted forgetful I have
to lose track of what I'm supposed to be
doing or what ready done god
first I'm so forgetful unbelievably yeah
it's me alright so that was the first
half how'd I do
your total is eight out of nine a score
of five or higher suggests inattention
is a problem for you while most people
struggle with some of these symptoms
that doesn't mean they have ADHD that
could be stressed by major life events
or any number of medical issues see
doesn't have to be anything we're gonna
look at hyperactivity next now I don't
think I don't think I have hyperactivity
because I I believe I was diagnosed with
a DD not ADHD all we shall see got apart
toe you probably don't bounce around
like a hyperactive child but perhaps you
feel often restless driven like there's
a dynamo inside of you maybe you're
impatient on the go thoughts race
sometimes tumbling ricocheting as you
pour out one idea after another you may
crave excitement of trying new things or
love highly stimulating activities with
a big payoff yet sounds awesome
physically restless fidgety aggro
fidgety during meetings classes and
church I can become angsty antsy during
long conversations I fidget with keys
bracelets coins and pens twirl my hair
doodle these things help me focus and
listen actually no I've never been one
to do this I've never been one of the
foot tapper like things like that
repetitive things and just like antsy
nature has never been like I am the most
patient guy in the world so I've
actually no on this one I feel they need
to get up on and move oh yeah this one
is me because when I'm watching a movie
or anything like that I have to be
standing like everyone else in the room
can be sitting but I have to be standing
and pacing around like I just I have to
do that Restless I'm impatient or
agitated when things are quiet I feel
rush pressured or driven even doing
something that isn't urgent I have
frequent job changes and move frequently
yep I do I say in my new apartment
difficulty enjoying leisure activities
quietly I find it hard to relax or work
quietly small talk is boring I always
have to be trying new things for
changing them up I'm always pushing the
envelope tweaking and adjusting god I am
my light the reason why my background
and my lighting setup changes so much is
because I fiddle with it all the time
everyone gets on my case about it I am a
fiddler
I love fiddling ah I can be over the top
center of attention some would say I'm a
bit immature prone to drama
everything it's a big deal with me no it
always seems like I'm on the go driven
by a motor I'm drawn to one hobby or
obsession after another I have more
stamina enthusiasm than anyone else if
it's something I find interesting I dive
in whole hog like a whirling dervish
with tons of energy but then suddenly
crash I'm more of a sprinter than a
marathoner yeah that's me I dive in so
hard like the last time I got completely
obsessed with something I started a
YouTube channel and now I'm feeling the
same way about music and I'm not I'm
being very hesitant about it not rude
but talkative I always have lots to say
but I'm not so great at listening I can
be an enthusiastic chatterbox who can't
stop if someone else tries to speak I
get louder because I feel pressure to
get it out I tend to dominate
conversations telling great stories but
rarely learning anything about anyone
else I always have to top or map someone
else's story now see you may think that
I would say yes to this but actually in
personal conversation I am the opposite
I love listening
I love engaging in conversation but I
have a great mind to share and not just
dominate the conversation like I'm a
good speaker I am I'm a great public
speaker and I love the sound of my own
voice but don't get me wrong a normal
one-to-one conversation like it I'll
listen more than I'll say so no blurting
out I'm full of ideas my mind jumps
ahead and races I don't sit quietly and
consider but immediately offer one idea
or opinion after another it may seem
impatient or dominating always adding my
two cents having to contribute my ideas
and I have lots of them I'm instantly
enthusiastic and interested in new
challenges I say yes to everything and
then end up overwhelmed with commitments
now I'm like half on this I'm not one to
just blurt out every idea in my mind in
certain sessions like brainstorming
sessions you need that but I'm actually
reserved until I have an idea that I
think is decent maybe not good but
decent so I might say no waiting my turn
is frustrating I hate lineups or waiting
for other people to arrive I will move
from one checkout line to another
seeking the fastest cashier who doesn't
do that I'll go out of my way to avoid
slow traffic well ok or long
conversations I can't stand people who
speak slowly
small talk is painfully boring a friend
who asked the waitress f out every item
on the menu makes me go crazy hate
waiting for other people to arrive I
can't just sit back and rise well this
is like an everybody question who
wouldn't answer yes for this I interrupt
and intrude on others I interrupt chime
in or intrude into other people's
conversation I'm gonna go ahead and know
I've already answered this I don't do
that that's that's rude that's
rude
I got manners that's rude what am I am I
totally ADHD your total score for
hyperactivity and impulsivity is 5 out
of 9 the threshold is 5 the
predominantly confined subtype of ADHD
ok what does that mean since you scored
a 5 or more in Part 1 this suggests you
may have what is called predominantly
combined subtype of ADHD this is the
most common type of ADHD but it sounds
like it's a bunch of but this
test online must be long so there goes
my fate I have ADHD what a revelation
this is I got to tell my doctor who
diagnosed me for ADHD that I have ADHD
according to this day on the Internet
but either way this is a test
online but actually the questions are
kind of interesting even though they
seem pretty broad in their application
so for those of you who have ADHD up
there just know it's okay you're gonna
get through life just fine no matter
what you do I've had ADHD on medication
and off I'm able to concentrate more
when I'm on it I take adderall and when
I'm off it I get a little zany but you
know give and take it is what it is it
doesn't impede me on my normal
day-to-day life but it does help me work
when I need to get down and work so that
is all for this video thank you
everybody who joined me on this quiz how
did you do what do you have I'll put a
link into this test in the description
below but don't take it as truth it is
just a guide so thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]